darker okay Devin Booker the Union cat  from Phoenix I'll check back in with you  at the top Devin with five on the first  rack that's a good start for him so much  efficiency much like clay in this tree  he does not off the ground all that  money nice rhythm see where round out  the shooters regular shot was still good  enough  Thompson so the ball goes in I'm  noticing the follow-through but the  backspin on the ball it seems that this  ball has no revolutions in the address  where that goes through is he licking  the risk that much harder if this just  seemed like that and you know what  looking at this record here this is the  second time he's always picked up the  second ball versus  three  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  you gotta be the females